I'm Paul Miller I'm the chief scientific
officer for antibacterial research
advisor
a principle that that one has to learn
early on here is that your you're going
to learn constantly but in terms of the
big picture success in individual
programs you can experience a lot more
failure than you are success and you you
have to accept that as a price of doing
business I think we have ourselves
focused very very specifically on trying
to reduce the frequency of failure or
increase the frequency of success but we
know that we're still going to fail more
often than we succeed but I think the
the fact that discovering and being part
of the discovery process for a new
life-saving therapy is such a rare
accomplishment among all of the
activities that human beings can
participate in that it's incredibly
compelling and it's motivating so you
have this opportunity to both learn and
once or twice in your career do
something absolutely remarkable in terms
of changing the situation for patients
tuberculosis would be a big one this is
a disease that affects up to a third of
the people on the planet carry that the
bacterium that causes tuberculosis so
this is a huge problem and in certain
parts of the world it is such an issue
that it really holds back economic
development and progress in those
societies so being able to do something
fundamentally as important as reduce the
severity of that disease and make this
less of a burden for society that would
be a big one I think HIV is another one
although that's outside of the scope of
research for my group but clearly a
current high priority is to address some
of these really problematic
gram-negative infections that we're
seeing in the hospital because we're
hearing from the advocacy groups from
the clinical community community and
some of the organizations that represent
them that this is public enemy number
one in our hospitals today and that we
need to deal with it beyond that I have
a daughter who has type 1 diabetes and I
would love to see cures there I you know
if I had the right training I would
immerse myself in that I think she's
handling the disease great she's healthy
she's a wonderful wonderful girl but
it's one of those problems that it would
it would be terrific to be able to
result
really just about all the genetic tools
that we use today when we talk about
genetics as a broader society began in
either bacteria or in viral virus
systems because they're much simpler
much more easy to manipulate in the
tools and the principles were worked out
there and then we've more recently
succeeded in applying those two more
complex situations like human diseases
in human genomes and human inheritance
of problems in genetic disorders for us
though we use genetics routinely and
genetics is forced on us routinely by
bacteria by that I mean that bacteria
are organisms that grow and replicate
rapidly and changes in our genetic
makeup often comes about as a
consequence of replication of our DNA
and mistakes that happen when DNA is
replicated we see this in cancer quite a
bit that changes in the evolution of a
tumor or even the very appearance of a
tumor are related to the fact that tumor
cells are replicating very rapidly and
can evolve in very different ways
bacteria do that too they do that quite
quickly and quite successfully and where
that impacts us is in antibiotic
resistance so one of the traits that
they may acquire or develop during the
course of this replication and growth
when they're causing infection is the
ability to be unaffected by an
antibiotic that we're giving them or
become resistant so that's a bit of
genetics that bacteria seem to exploit
in terms of being able to get around the
antibiotic therapies we provide for them
we turn that around a bit by using
genetic tools to find some of the
potential Achilles heels in bacteria so
working with bacteria in the laboratory
we apply an array of tools to determine
which genes and gene functions and
therefore processes are essential for
the survival of these bacteria and
therefore identify potential targets for
new small molecules chemicals or perhaps
antibodies that
could be successfully used to inhibit
the growth of those bacteria if the
pharmaceutical industry the
biopharmaceutical industry including
smaller companies were to completely
leave this area of research we would be
in big trouble because that very genetic
nature of bacteria that we just talked
about their ability to grow and evolve
and develop resistance means that
they're always going to be working on
the next problem so we need to continue
to work on the next solution and
therefore if we weren't working on that
at all as a society or as an industry I
think we would be in big trouble
a consolidated view of what a superbug
is is a species of bacteria that we're
familiar with that we're aware of that
takes on an additional characteristic
that rather abruptly and suddenly makes
it far less easy to address than it used
to be but we've heard that connotation
tagged to different bacteria over time
and while they have been very big
problems things like mrs a or
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus we've
been able to come up with solutions I do
think there are some potential super bug
problems that we need to be aware of
though a you know sort of a generic
description would be a very common
bacteria that not only becomes resistant
to most of the antibiotics that are
normally used for it but that becomes
much more aggressive in terms of how
quickly it goes from an initial
infection to putting the patient in a
very precarious position so when those
kind of events happen that's when the
medical community i think is quite off
guard with respect to what it's dealing
with and one of the challenges then is
what is that gap in time between when we
become aware of that problem and when
we're able to deliver a solution so yeah
there are things like that that keep us
on our toes all the time
idea of a pre-competitive work i think
is gaining a lot of traction in the
industry and within Pfizer it's
something that we're exploring a lot
more actively right now you know we've
come to acknowledge the fact that while
we have you know the largest
pharmaceutical R&D investment in the
industry across all of the disease areas
that we work in we're still a small
fraction of the total biomedical
research investment that's out there so
it really would be a little bit
presumptuous of us to believe that
within these walls we have all of the
answers that will be able to come up
with all the answers we need there's a
lot of smart people out there and a lot
of people that we'd love to partner with
we're willing to partner with us and so
yes we are actively exploring those
kinds of things can we work together to
generate some fundamental knowledge that
will allow us to go off and then come up
with those new small molecule
antibiotics or drugs in whatever disease
area we're working in so that is
becoming a big thing when we're
exploring the way that that publicly
available information open access types
tools might be able to enable those
kinds of conversations we're exploring
things like looking for funding for
these kinds of partnerships from sources
outside our walls because the the
research that we're doing is becoming
increasingly expensive so not only can
we not assume that we can intellectually
solve all these problems we probably
can't afford to try to solve all of
these problems but we want to contribute
in a way that makes sense for us so what
are we really good at what do we bring
to the table well there's a lot of drug
discovery and development expertise in
an applied sense that's only found
inside a pharmaceutical company like
Pfizer let's bring that to the table
what other kinds of knowledge to other
people bring to the table how can we
pull that together to get solutions
because we all want the same thing
I think that our understanding of how
human genomics is going to play a role
in helping us understand which patients
are most likely to respond to a new
therapy so all patients are not created
equal that may have a particular medical
problem that has brought them to our
attention at this moment but we have to
understand that in the context of other
genetic issues or environmental issues
they may be facing or their age or other
thing so being able to put that together
and using the information from the human
genome and their understanding of how
genetic networks play together to add up
to the health care status of a person i
think is going to be incredibly
enlightening it's going to allow us to
develop drugs more quickly because we'll
know which patients are more likely to
respond to a therapy than others will
get the right patients in a clinical
trial and be able to test it more
effectively for infectious diseases I
think learning about the host is also a
potential breakthrough opportunity for
us because we not only need to think
about how did the bugs work but how do
we as patients or host for those
pathogens respond to the presence of a
pathogen some people never get sick you
know these people walking around they
need to seem to never get a cold other
people get everyone that comes by what
is the difference in our makeup that
makes some of us more susceptible to
infections that others what may what is
it that contributes to get appropriately
responding so we also know that some
patients in the hospital when they get a
bacterial infection respond with a very
strong immune response that actually is
more of a problem than the bacteria
itself it's a can lead to a syndrome
called sepsis where the inflammatory
system actually sort of goes haywire in
its desire to deal with the pathogen you
know dampening that down in
understanding the network controlling
that is another opportunity that I think
will come to us from from human genomics
so I see that as an area that is just
going to open up a whole host of
solutions to us
it occurs to me that cancer obviously is
an area that certainly benefit from this
we know that not all cancers are the
same not all patients develop of the
same manifestations of cancer and that
there are familial linkages you know
that are related to the propensity to
develop certain types of cancers versus
others and the interplay between our
genes in the environment there does
translate into you know a situation that
affects cancer I think there's a lot of
promise their diabetes again is another
genetic when both type 1 and type 2 or I
think there is the potential to learn a
lot and to me I think the the whole
central nervous system and an area focus
for our neurosciences group what
contributes to some manifestations of
various psychosis propensity to get
Alzheimer's disease autism things like
that I think all of those will benefit
substantially from from breakthroughs in
human genomic